[Music]
what's going on guys one thing you know
for certain
we here at screen junkies love toys
that's right we're surrounded by them
action figures collectibles and they're
coming out related to movies all the
time and in fact there's a movie
inspired by toys coming out shortly max
steel this all got me thinking what are
the most popular movie toys of all time
we're about to get to the bottom of that
and we have a couple of experts with us
today to talk about it with first he is
the head man of action at the website
action figure insider welcome to screen
junkies Daniel Pickett thanks for being
here my pleasure and he's a friend of
the show you've seen one movie fights he
is the founder of I mockery calm and the
creator of abobo's big adventure
Roger bar good to be back hell and
missed you so guys um would it be fair
to call you both collectors oh yeah hi
sometimes holder yeah depending on if
you talk to my wife word I am here yeah
how did each of you start collecting I
mean I feel like I've been a collector
of my whole life it started back in the
70s with Mego figures those you know
8-inch figures with the cloth costume
let me go rule the earth for a long time
they were actually the first company to
do movie licensing Roger tell us a
little bit about your early foray into
collective I was also a big amiga fan
absolutely um but my main thing when I
was a kid was I got to grow up in like
the Golden Age of toys of the 80s
yeah she have some of the figures that
came out that I mean Masters of the
Universe GI Joe real American hero
transformers Robo force so many great
toy lines back then back then they did
have giant sets like the GI Joe aircraft
carrier the USS Flagg you could sleep on
top of that thing as a kid it was oh
yeah I had the GI Joe aircraft carrier
you were spoiled it was the greatest
Hanukkah present I ever received
I can't imagine owning that that thing
must have been amazing oh um we had a
basement and um you need 170 it only got
75% built but that was enough fellas
would it be fair to say that toy
collecting can you can simply break it
down to pre and post Star Wars not
necessarily Star Wars
was the 800-pound gorilla I mean Star
Wars got a lot of people into it and
kept a lot of people the biggest movie
toy line of all time for Star Wars what
was or what were the biggest toys you
mentioned migos was there one that's
like oh this line or this particular
character was far and away me go where
it was the first company I mean they had
the Marvel license the DC license which
is you know at the time unheard of Wow
they got everything back then yeah it
was crazy that you know because of most
of times they try and mix that around
like Oh someone's gonna do this I'm
gonna do this
so after Star Wars what was the next big
property to rear its head that impact of
the toy industry movie wise I would
probably say Batman coming out with the
89 Batman absolutely mostly came out
yeah in 90 and again carried through to
today so what are some of the big pieces
from that release everyone wanted like
the Batmobile and the bat wings I mean
those are two of the most iconic things
from the movie so yeah those were
definitely big ones I remember just
being so excited to finally have that
bat way later in the 90s mid to late 90s
we had more Batman films the Joel
Schumacher Batman films were there any
toys of note coinciding with those films
for Batman Forever yeah I made this
awesome Batcave it had like three
pedestals that connected with bridges it
has this big lattice that you can hang
the batwing on you know there was a ramp
you could bring the the Batmobile in I
mean it was a giant place yeah and
playsets were kind of starting to fade
out at that point too so this was like
it was a big deal to toy collectors and
so that was one that I was a thing of
magic the company that first put out the
the figures for the 89 Batman was
relatively unknown it was a company
called toy biz this was their first
venture into action figures so they did
the Batman figures they eventually
expanded that into more DC figures and
then they moved into the Marvel license
oh for Marvel Comics and then eventually
they were bought by Marvel and for a
period they owned Marvel while Marvel
was bankrupt oh wow yeah so Marvel owned
by toy biz yeah after Batman 1989 what
really made an impact on the industry
after that
for me I would say mcfarlanes movie
maniacs that was a huge one because up
until that time kids really didn't have
action figures based on rated R movies
these were gory horror figures I mean
you had leather face they had bloody
variants which were extra bloody that
you know I had like a bucket with
severed body parts and ends up and these
were being sold at KB toys and Toys R Us
they're for kids to just buy imagine
hurt yeah what you pretty unheard of at
that time so and these covered like
pretty much every major horror movie
property you had Elm Street you had
Friday 13th Halloween army of Darkness
ash gotta figure Oh candy man even gotta
figure so we've journeyed through the
70s into the 80s into the 90s I want to
ask about another film that originated
in that era Jurassic Park
talk to me about that influence on toys
as they were developing the the
dinosaurs the thinking was there's lots
of dinosaur toys out there what is going
to set this apart right and one of the
guys pitched well if we put the Jaypee
mark on them they'll know they're
authentic Jurassic Park toys and that
will make kids want to buy them over
just a generic dinosaur because
dinosaurs are public domain anyone can
make a dinosaur true yeah the 90's was
actually quite a mess like as far as
movie figures go when you think about
there was Kevin Costner's Robin Hood
they did figures based on that and they
basically repurposed the Star Wars II
walk village as one of these sets from
that well the bodies are superpowers
figures and so some of those the Star
Wars figures like the Amorian guards
yeah fire talk revealing some secrets
here to the point where Kevin Costner's
belt buckle has a G on it because it was
the Green Arrow figure from superpowers
Wow yeah you heard it here so moving
into the 2000s I mean some of the
obvious ones that come to mind are just
more DC more Batman and Marvel became
such a huge player uh and transformers I
mean okay well yes movie came out as
where there were whole halves of aisles
dedicated gotcha
thought so okay so uh take me into how
transformers because
that's a toy that existed kind of faded
away then back with a vengeance so you
know when when what collectors call them
the bay formers okay when those came out
I think that created a certain amount of
issues just because the transformation
of the CG models didn't have to be
realistic it didn't have to function but
then toy makers still had to make them
do that yeah because in the movie I mean
half of these things just look like a
bunch of sheet metal stuck together and
painted you know and flat on a
personality oh they have really don't a
lot of old-school collectors didn't
necessarily gravitate to it but kids ate
it up and they sold like gangbusters and
especially the you know that was a
summer movie that Christmas stores were
wiped out of that stuff Wow okay so that
sounds huge fellows that uh did Star
Wars
talk to me so when the movie came out
they weren't expecting it to be that
huge you know even though the cast was
like I don't know what this is gonna be
that's why Lucas got the rights to it
cuz right I didn't think it was gonna
matter is that even thought they would
get a sequel little did they know
everyone underestimated this thing so
Kenner was the company that got the
license they were not prepared for
Christmas of 1977
so they had some puzzles and some like
well paint-by-number things but they had
no action figures and they realized that
was a huge mistake so what they did was
they sold the earlybird kit which was
basically a cardboard stand that some
day you could put figures on without
right uh uh and had some stickers and it
had a little thing that you would mail
in and in six to eight months then we'll
get you your figure so what happened
with the with the crushing demand they
put out this early bird get parents
wrapped it put it under the tree and
you'd open and go yeah look at that
peace of God for them is your great yeah
and then eventually they did though I
guess I got one I mailed the thing in
and just one day I went to the mailbox
and there was Luke Leia Chewbacca and
r2d2 just waiting for Oh spectacular
oh and that kicked it off and from there
then you started to see the toy stores
just fill up with them I'm yes
floor-to-ceiling Star
where's toys I mean you can look up some
photos of them online just how beautiful
these old classic toy aisles was done
just so much stuff and it's crazy to
think how valuable because these were
just mass-produced back then but now
they're just skyrocketed in values so
Star Wars really was kind of the dawning
of a new era absolutely it was it was
one of the first what they call
evergreen properties that just sort of
stays I mean it ran from 78 84 85 yeah 5
in its initial run yeah are there
anything from that line that are
considered like a Holy Grail piece one
of the big Star Wars stories is the
rocket-firing Boba Fett's Oh which we
entered denies they ever even produced
right away yeah so yeah right before
Empire came out lace they released that
new wave there was a thing you could cut
out 5 proof of purchase send it in for
this new character from Empire Strikes
Back yeah
Boba Fett they had the sort of crude
mock-up of him on the back and he had a
rocket that would shoot out of its
backpack more like this was fantastic
oh yeah yeah grants the first one was
like an action feature and so we all cut
up our cards and mail it in and then we
got the thing and there was a nice
little note saying hey uh we took out
that feature because it you know it was
leaking heavy onto his back yak instead
if one was to come across one of those
how much would it set you back Oh
somewhere somewhere between ten and
twenty thousand dollars yeah Hachi machi
biggest toy franchise still Star Wars
really yeah Wow yeah makes sense makes
sense it's 38 years later and we're
still lining up at midnight when they
now those are Wars still rules okay
even though where's our Wars prequels
honestly those I mean people were lying
up because well you know what I realized
point they knew all these toys were
collectible so they're like let's buy
them up and um I feel like I've realized
that for a lot of young people those are
their Star Wars movies you know so I
asked you both earlier what's the
weirdest film ever to have toys made for
it and you both said over the top into
the time independently of each other
other than uh yes over the top the
Sylvester Stallone armwrestling film Oh
slow motion the knuckles cracking and
Roger you own this yet this is
one of our wrestling table yeah there's
actually you cannot use this unless you
have the figure yes no I do have the
figures as well you guys you've given us
such a bountiful gift of information
it's almost as good as the gift of the
GI Joe aircraft carrier I received that
one on Oh guys thank you for really uh
dropping some knowledge so what's your
favorite movie toy you own is there
something that you're searching for that
you can't wait to have have you already
bought your rogue one action figures let
us know in the comments section below we
want to know
Daniel picket thank you for being here
and just spreading so much knowledge
Rodger bar ah always good to have you
back right every bad buddy and thank you
for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up
on Twitter bye bye hey guys did you know
that this end card works with your phone
now I know right click the boxes below
to watch more screen junkies videos and
click the screen junkies logo to
subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more